et on part à présent à la chasse aux
fausses infos
[Musique]
un faut intox c'est avec vous Anthony
Saint-Léger bonjour bonjour sur les
réseaux sociaux à plusieurs internautes
ce scandalisent d'une affiche
publicitaire elle invite à vacciner des
nouveaux-nés contre le covid-19
effectivement une affiche à diffuser
depuis plusieurs jours maintenant par
des comptes opposés à la vaccination
contre le covid 19 on y voit donc ce
bébé ce slogan adapté à l'approche des
fêtes de fin d'année avec mes deux
vaccins papiers et mamie seront près du
sapin plusieurs logos officiels
notamment celui de l'ARS l'Agence
Régionale de la Santé qui comme son nom
l'indique est chargé d'élaborer la
politique de la santé à l'échelle
régionale de quoi cette campagne qui
incite donc à vacciner les bébés les
nouveaux nés et les nourrissons
offusques certains à l'image de cette
internaute par exemple des affiches
criminelles des communications
criminelles laissez les gosses en dehors
de vos bêtises soyons polis
expliquez-nous pourquoi cette affiche
n'est pas authentique et bien on va
procéder en plusieurs étapes on va
d'abord se rendre sur le site de l'ARS
l'Agence Régionale de la Santé donc où
l'on ne retrouve aucune trace de cette
campagne ce qui est plutôt étrange en
revanche on trouve une autre campagne en
loop qui mêle grippe et covid 19 et qui
utilise la même charte graphique et une
partie du slogan une campagne incarnée
par cette personne âgée qui nous dit
avec mes deux vaccins je crains des
gains des gains un mot venu d'Occitanie
pour dire personne et pour cause puisque
cette campagne nous vient de l'ARS PACA
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur et elle a été
lancée en 2021 mais on va procéder une
autre étape et en l'occurrence celle-ci
c'est l'analyse for racing ce qui permet
de repérer toutes les petites retouches
toutes les petites manipulations
incohérences graphique d'une image il y
a plusieurs outils souvent gratuit qui
sont à disposition il vous suffit de
renseigner ici le
fichier en question et vous obtenez
c'est ce qu'on a fait à différentes
l'image analysées par différents filtres
alors c'est un décryptage assez complexe
et je précise aussi que c'était pas une
recette 100% miracle ça ne prouve pas
qu'il y a un trucage à 100 % mais en
tout cas ça met sur la voie et en
l'occurrence pour l'image qui nous
intéresse j'ai sélectionné deux filtres
qui vont montrer la différence entre
l'image originale et à l'image truquée
regardez ici il y a beaucoup de points
rouges ici sur le slogan truqué ici sur
le bébé ici sur le logo qui a été
rajouté pareil ici alors ça ça monte
davantage une compression graphique le
fait qu'il y ait beaucoup de points
rouges et ici une différence de qualité
graphique aussi et puis ça ne s'arrête
pas mal puisque lorsque l'on fait une
recherche d'image inversée et bien on
retrouve le bébé dans une banque d'image
en ligne CQFD autre exemple de photo
montage Anthony les une de journaux oui
c'est assez classique regardez cet
exemple plusieurs publications qui
partagent depuis quelques jours
maintenant depuis le début du mois
notamment cette une de cette fausse une
présentant au sous la funderline la
présidente de la Commission européenne
comme la femme la plus criminelle
d'Europe et pour compléter ce portrait
peut flatteur se sous-titre qui nous dit
l'ultra mondialiste peut transformer
l'Europe en un état central totalitaire
aider de ces fascistes du Forum
économique mondial cela aurait des
conséquences extrêmes pour nous alors il
n'y a pas de nom de journal mais il y a
un logo cette étoile qui va nous
renvoyer au Stern étoiles donc en
allemand le magazine hebdomadaire qui
est assez connu pour ses couvertures à
scandales en témoigne celle-ci doute
2017 on y voit Donald Trump faisant un
salut nazi ce titre zincampf son combat
mais surtout référence au mont combat
mein camp de Adolf Hitler et ce
sous-titres néonazi Q Klux Klan racisme
comment don contraintes remuent la haine
aux États-Unis
elle n'a pas fait la une du magazine
allemand effectivement et on va vous
montrer pourquoi ce n'est pas le cas on
va revenir à la une en question le
détail il se trouvait ici il faut avoir
l'oeil regardez on distingue le numéro
de l'édition et la date de parution 22
septembre 2022 et le numéro 39 on se
rend donc sur le site du Stern où il y a
évidemment toutes les couvertures et à
l'édition 39 regardez qui vous trouvez
pas de trace d'oursela fonde derrière
layonne mais de Georgia melloni celle
qui quelques jours après le 22 septembre
devenait présidente du Conseil italien
la
pardon la femme d'extrême droite
présenté ici des peintres comme la femme
la plus dangereuse d'Europe et le
photomontage ne s'est pas arrêté là
parce que lorsque l'on compare les deux
une là une et la vraie vous voyez même
qu'une photo ici du président ukrainien
volo du avec un appel Odon info appel
aux dons a été ajouté merci Anthony
Saint-Léger c'était un faux int